if you're looking for more Fire and
Blood we've got you covered in this deep
dive into episode 8's preview if you
haven't checked it out yet I've left a
link to it in the description but please
do come back I'm lonelier than aegon
after eight glasses of wine be warned
this video unlike my episode breakdowns
is chock full of book spoilers let's not
waste any time and get right into it the
title of this episode is Lord of the
tides a reference to the head of house
valarian and judging by this preview
this story will center around who will
become heir to driftmark last episode
rainey's tried to convince her husband
to name Bayla as Heir instead of their
son lanor who would pass it on to Luke
the bastard one knot of true Valerian
blood but with Lenor now gone Luke is
one step closer to being Heir you may
also ask yourself how come it doesn't go
to Jace well that's because he'll be
king and it seems as though titles in
Westeros work in a similar fashion to
the British Monarchy meaning one can't
take a lower title if they have one
that's higher for example King Charles
can't simultaneously be known as the
Prince of Wales even though it was a
title he held for 64 years similarly
when Jace becomes king he'll be referred
to as such and not as lord of the tides
so that title will fall to next in line
Luke but as we'll see throughout this
preview there are others seeking to
claim this Title Here we see a ship
heading toward King's Landing with that
Dome structure it looks a lot like the
Royal ship we've seen viserys and
rhaenyra utilize throughout the season
it seems as though the king is Gravely
ill as Otto Hightower proclaims he
speaks on behalf of the king it was not
uncommon for the hand to sit on the
throne and perform the king's duties
while a king was Ill or indisposed
perhaps this is what renera means later
on in the preview when the high Towers
have quote struck the first blow with
the title of episode 9 being the green
Council the name of the council put
together after the death of the king to
prop up King aegon it looks as though
this or next episode will be king
viserys's last from pre previous
trailers we do know the king does in
fact die this season leading to the
dance of dragons a bloody Civil War here
we get a shot of rhaenyra in a black
dress if green is Allison's color then
black certainly is Rainier is behind her
we can definitely tell another jump has
happened with her son Jace and now
stepdaughter Bela several years older
and don't worry for those of you who
find these time jumps really jolting
apparently this is the last one for some
time another great shot of renera in her
black dress the attention to detail here
is amazing with the fabric creating
these dragon-like scales with hints of
crimson she looks a little concerned
over what's transpired here in the
throne room I wouldn't be too happy
either if a high tower was now claiming
to speak on behalf of the king
especially if that King is in ill health
we already saw how viserys forgetfully
called Alison Emma last episode if his
mental faculty has gotten worse who
knows how Otto could manipulate him here
is a fantastic shot showcasing some of
the old and new cast in the back left is
the ever faithful sworn protector of
Allison sir Kristen aegon is here doing
his best Draco Malfoy followed by Eamon
Helena Allison and Otto a few things to
note here aegon would be next in line to
the throne if viserys hadn't named
raniera air aemond having lost his eye
in episode 7 showcases his sweet new eye
patch Helena oddly enough isn't holding
on to any bugs I wonder if she's been
wed to aegon yet as was mentioned last
episode now take a look at Allison
whether she's faking this sadness or not
we don't know but it likely has to do
with the severity of her husband's
illness take a look at her green dress
also adorned with a quite visible faith
of the seven necklace it makes perfect
sense Allison would lean into religion
remember it was a young Allison who
prayed with rhaenyra in the earlier
episodes the faith of the seven is the
dominant religion in Westeros so it
would look good in the eyes of the
common folk plus it's in line with her
image of being this dutiful law-abiding
self-sacrificing mother a contrast to
rhaenyra who will be painted as the
complete opposite notably absent here is
Allison and viserys's fourth child
dayron I've heard that he won't appear
in season one in the book he spends most
of his youth in Old Town as cupbearer
and Squire to Allison's cousin Ormond
Hightower a close-up of aegon and his
brother Eamonn behind him I love this
small green emeralds lining his necklace
I just hope he's grown out of his window
phase another faith of the seven symbol
Atop The small Council where Allison
sits in the king's seat Alison has
attended small Council meetings before
but now it looks as though she's leading
them it appears news has reached
Dragonstone of the high Tower's ruling
in viserys's name and renera can't let
that happen if you'll remember at the
end of episode 7 the traumatic events of
that episode resulted in the high Towers
going back to King's Landing and
rhaenyra and Damon hunkering down on
Dragonstone where it's assumed that the
they've remained during this time I'm
even wondering if that's the Chamber of
the painted table in the background here
where many of the war meetings on
Dragonstone are held a visibly older
Damon agrees with his wife they are to
make their way to King's Landing to make
sure everything is on the up and up
could that ship we saw at the beginning
be rainera and Damons it seems pretty
empty but maybe they took their dragons
check out this creepy nighttime shot of
what appears to be someone who has had
their head bandaged in bed my first
thought was that this is King viserys
however since the next line refers to
the sea snake being injured in battle at
the damn step Stones no less I'm more
inclined to think this is coreless we
can make out a white-haired woman to the
right possibly his wife rhaenis
correction since I started editing this
video I noticed the windowed designs
here match those found in the king's
chamber where he is dead so unless
they're the same Design This is likely
viserys now I also wonder if viseris
will die a natural death or if someone
will give him a little push the book
offers two scenarios one in which the
king went for a nap and died in his
sleep and the other where Allison gives
the king some poison if anyone were to
give the king some poison I'd argue it
would be rainis as revenge for stealing
her crown here appears to be a maester
or surgeon preparing some surgical tools
when we find renice in front of dozens
of candles whenever I think of many
candles in Game of Thrones I think of
religion so maybe she's praying to some
sort of God or the gods for her
husband's recovery someone who may not
be praying for corliss's Recovery is his
brother vehmond these two have fought a
lot and vaman knows that Luke who's
expected to be Lord of driftmark isn't a
true Valerian so it would make sense
with Corliss potentially on his deathbed
for vaman to come and claim driftmark as
his own we'll later see him questioning
renice who sits on the Driftwood Throne
asking who will sit on it when Corliss
is gone it looks as though training
continues at King's Landing where sir
Kristen abashes Eamonn shield with a
Morning Star just like he did to Damon
in episode 1 overlooking the ominous in
Grim King's Landing we have voice over
of a feeble voiced viserys stating the
crown cannot remain strong if the house
of the Dragon is divided the man is
still holding on to hope that Allison
and radera can patch things up and heal
the rift between their families here we
have Jason Luke watching someone come
through the front Gates of the red keep
someone will later find is abayment
vaman's arrival will undoubtedly cause
more problems for many of our characters
especially if he starts questioning
these strong boy's legitimacy to the
throne when it pertains to driftmark
here we have Damon clutching a piping
hot dragon egg but for whom could this
egg be for maybe his daughter Reina who
had vegar snatch from her or perhaps one
of the three children he'll eventually
have with rhaenyra I'm curious if this
egg is discovered at the dragon pit or
on Dragonstone this looks like Jace to
me visibly upset and with aegon to his
right I wouldn't be surprised if he was
the cause of this anger a cloaked figure
of approaching massaria aka the White
Worm the last we saw of her she ratted
on Damon to Otto Hightower about his
secret died out with rhaenyra as far as
we know Damon does not know it was her
who did this the cloak here suggests
that this is Damon could he be going
back to her to cheat or perhaps asking
for a favor she is well connected with
spies after all it also looks like
Masari is doing quite well for herself
neatly dressed and in an upscale home a
far cry from the prostitute she was in
episode 1. rhaenyra tells Damon here
that this is a trap by going to King's
Landing there's definitely the potential
for lots of traps here's Luke looking a
little concerned followed by eamond
pointing his sword saying nephews of
course referring to Jason Luke if
Episode 7 was Kitty brawl here we have
teen brawl Jace punches Eamon but we can
also see Luke and aegon here and even a
glimpse of Helena in the background
aegon pushes Luke into the table and
just check out the face of who I think
is Reina beside him the preview ends
with Auto telling whomever is in the
king's seat at the small Council likely
Alison that the threat of War looms
because the next shot is of Raymond's
rival in King's Landing it implies that
this may be where the threat comes from
however I wouldn't be surprised if this
threat of war is more in regards to the
potential Civil War on the horizon when
the King dies and Rainier's claim is
threatened I would imagine vaman would
Ally himself with the high Towers he'd
want driftmark over the bastard to Luke
and if Rainier is on the throne he'll
never get it it's also quite interesting
to note here that vehemen is accompanied
into the red keep by Hightower soldiers
not the King's Landing guard adding
further proof a high tower vehemen
Alliance may be on the horizon whatever
happens next it seems to be heading
towards the dance of dragons one of the
bloodliest events Westeros has ever
experienced thanks for watching everyone
be sure to like And subscribe and leave
a comment on what you think will happen
next and if you haven't seen my episode
7 breakdown be sure to check that out
for more bad takes you can follow me on
Twitter Instagram at thinkstory YT until
next time remember
where is my grandson